Hôm nay, mình có nhiều tầm mắm của trong phục mạng
Puy trên mức nguồn dần
Còn cái mình rất dựa vãi trên nguồn
mà thằng cửi chơi nhanh
làm thật hỏi bai rồi
vì đừng có hân mềm nó đi
mê tởi chẳng anh nhận ngồi
sẽ nó y chuyện hả?
Con tội mặt cho buông
Cái hả?
Con tội mạng đi này, đất hệ rồi này
Bboo bước ngỳ ngỳ mặt
Không còn tróng hồi làm hồi
Bboo bước ngỳ ngỳ đủ
Chắc bị trạng của kịch mà khỏi uôi
Có cả của lại phương tiệt nội tay
Mình sẽ mấy đẹp mấy đẹp dạy ra,
dạy ra dừng có ra tỷ trái sế
tình ở bùng mặt của chút
không có gì nhé mấy trạm
nó đưa không tắc
đưa mình có tu mà đến
để xả nội
chỉ có tầm bơi để 1 2 phút
có nhiều mấy mình và mất tầm bụt nhanh phút
và tầm mình lại xe thì mình lại rất
áp lực bị đường
rất đông rất lắm rồi
thì mình phải chờ đợi
thì mình phải đứt tắc
cho mình là mình đứt
và chắc tế
rất tầy là mình đảo mình chạy cộp với tầy dàng
nhưng mà trong cái sịt của làm như này
mà mạnh trải đua với chính thương của hợp thắt
dù có thắt đường
hông thắt đường
đều ở gì chính rất là nhàng
thì mình có gắng đối uổi
để tiếp tận được
mình nhắn cơ cơ cơ cơ cơ
và thường cã nhắn
gấp khoảng hướng mời lên
tốc lộ thằng của
kết cấu hạp tầm cho thân
rất lĩnh là cái tình trà
uống thắt ra thông trên
đẹp bà đường lộ
hết sức xúc tạc
đạc biệt tròn những ngày
cật tế
vẹp đầu tư kết cấu hạp tầm ra thông
chứ thỏng kịp
nhở khai tính đường
bánh đàn
chứ cường tầm
chứ được nổ thương
thao đúng quý hạp